bonjour michel raison merci de répondre
à nos questions vous serez reçus d'ici
moins d'une heure bien sûr par edouard
philippe à matignon pour lui remettre
officiellement votre rapport que comptez
vous dit au premier ministre pour le
convaincre de changer d'avis sur cette
mesure qui doit maintenant être
appliquée d'ici 15 jours 1 sachant qu'il
a déjà eu le temps de le consulter
puisqu'on lui a fait remettre par le
président larcher est ce qu'on pense des
mois d'avril
pensez que vous pouvez encore lui faire
changer d'avis je pense que ce sera
difficile
par contre on va continuer de développer
nos arguments mais on le fait pas pour
l'offensé c'est ce qu'on avait vu
d'ailleurs dans un certain nombre de
communiqués de presse c'est une main
tendue parce que on n'est jamais sûr
d'avoir raison bien sûr et moi le
premier mais lorsqu'à pas loin de 80 %
des français une dizaine de ministres
pratiquement tous les départements de
france faut quand même se poser des
questions donc on va re développer un
certain nombre d'arguments pour essayer
de le convaincre pour le rendre service
la recommandation principale que vous
faites dans ce rapport c'est de
décentraliser au niveau des départements
ça fait d'ailleurs c'est un geste
politique fort parce que au moment où
l'état recentralise un certain nombre de
décisions va lui démontrer que c'est
fort possible
on a déjà dans nos départements n'a
correct le préfet placer des tronçons à
70 km/heure dans nos propres villes on a
tous été plus ou moins mère un jour ou
l'autre on a mis des zones à 30 on n'a
pas demandé au premier ministre qu'il
fasse confiance aux lutins
c'est pas des sauvages ils sont
également des grands défenseurs de la
sécurité routière
donc il a tort de s'entêter donc ce que
vous proposez dans ce rapport c'est un
véritable dispositif alternatif à
alternatif avec une prise de
responsabilité des gens de terrain qui
de terrain bouquet parfois un peu
galvaudé mais qui connaissent
parfaitement la situation mais ne pas
généraliser 400 mille kilos mais
d'autres peut-être plus d'ailleurs ce
qu'on n'a peut-être pas compté les
routes communales et c'est vraiment
ridicule et contre-productive et quand
edouard philippe dit que ça va sauver
400 vies chaque année
mais dans ses réponses et il en sait
rien
j'en sais rien c'est une grande majorité
des experts ces bases et oui mais c'est
basé sur des études très virtuel donc
j'espère qu'on va continuer de sauver
des vies en particulier d'ailleurs être
des mise à deux fois deux routes avec
les progrès technologiques sur les
voitures et avec plus de responsabilité
des conducteurs d'ailleurs y avoir 120
radar de modifier cette année il va y
avoir aussi beaucoup plus de contrôler
ça on a besoin de contrôler mais à
partir du moment où vous serez à 80 km
c'est plus du contrôle s'adresse à ceux
qui défendent la thèse du racket vous
finir par avoir raison
je te le désert la mesure entre en
vigueur au 1er juillet d'ici quinze
jours vous pensez réellement encore
changer les choses vous savez même si on
n'arrive pas à changer les choses
les combats qui sont perdus c'est ce
qu'on n'a pas conduit ça c'est connu et
j'ose espérer que le combat qu'on vienne
conduire le travail très sérieux qu'on a
fourni tout à fait en dehors de la
politique politicienne portera forcément
un jour ses fruits très bien merci
beaucoup merci michel raison